oh
i think we both want to put an end to the
bloodshed mostly because we want to go eat fried
fish and drink white wine together huzzah with a
saffron aioli yes larvae only and as neither of
these old can win nor do they seem able to lose
we should come to a deal we are again shut up
agreed you have sway with poland and
with denmark of course they love me
i suspect you wishes to seek an end to the
trade embargo with was i talking to you
manage your people say peter hola shut up yes
of course we can and you must [ __ ] off out of
you know where is it russia yeah i will move
my men out of cairo this is capitulation we own
that chatty sanders yes i thought this would be
difficult but actually negotiations are easy maybe
i'm just good at it you know i say what i want you
say what you want and we both agree huzzah huzzah
and of course in petersburg what it's in
petersburg i say again what and you shall note the
shift in my tone i know it seems big
but some petersburg was always swedish
for 400 years until your father stole it
from us 30 years ago stole it uh he won it
you [ __ ] lost it and then he turned
a [ __ ] hole into a grand city
i know you don't want to live under the
past glories and failures of your father
peter honestly as your friend if you seek a clean
slate as emperor the best thing for you to do is
to give some petersburg up huge why are you
ruining everything that city is a monstrous
shadow it's his city it's his victory none of
it yours all of it contextualizing you as a
puny leader of skinny achievement
did you just call me puny no but when placed
against him of course it looks that way ask
your people what i'm you are it ah you and
he thanks for making my point blaster guts
now you go to moscow you make that your base that
is the new center of russia from there you can be
your own man you could be your own emperor and
build your own russia i'm doing you a favor here
it's interesting yeah we'll just
think on it for a moment okay
here's your peace deal
suck on that
you're biting me
it's frustrating to wait outside the doors is
it not you would rather witness their idiocy
i would you swedish you're gonna drown in the
blood of your people i'm sorry you feel that way
mama's boy you know my father [ __ ] your mother
in the face after a state dinner in the face
there's 30 million of us and only two million
of you i don't care if four million of us
have to die to kill two million of you we're
russian we don't give off how many of us die
what has happened empress your husband is afraid
if this is news i apologize although i doubt
it is does this mean lunch is cancelled and me
you against a tree also cancelled we're leaving
you